und traubensirup ist das allererste
gucke ich die ganze Zeit rein mein Gott
das noch so gedippt in so Frischkäse
mega lecker
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute simit
für faule ich habe schon ein
originalsimit-rezept auf meinem Kanal
das werde ich euch in die Infobox
verlinken Sie mit in der türkische
sesamkringe ganz ganz typisch ob jetzt
zum Frühstück oder einfach so als Snack
zwischendurch und sie sind extrem lecker
und heute habe ich mir gedacht wenn ihr
mal keine Zeit habt aber Lust auf was
sie mit artiges habt dann nehmt euch
einfach Blätterteig ich schreibe euch
alle ganz genau Mengenangaben wie immer
hier unten in die Infobox dann könnt ihr
euch das einfach aufklappen und
screenshotten und wie gesagt habt ihr
den tiefgekühlten Blätterteig ihr könnt
auch den erfrischen nehmen und weil der
tiefgekühlte Blätterteig ja auch ein
bisschen breiter ist wird er jetzt hier
einmal halbiert
frischen Blätterteig könnt ihr dann
einfach nur so in Bahnen entlang
schneiden es ist eigentlich ziemlich
selbst erklärend und ihr merkt schon ich
lege auch direkt los hier es ist ein
sehr schnelles Rezept legt jetzt einfach
so übereinander das durfte bei mir schon
zehn Minuten antauen weil
tiefkühlblätterteig ist ja ein sich im
erstmal hart und nach zehn Minuten
wieder dann sehr weich hier einfach
zusammenpressen oder aber den Fingern
wasserdippen und hier mit Wasser noch
mal versiegeln und dann könnt ihr das
einmal einklappen
so und dann wird das einfach nur zu
einem Kringel eingedreht und dann zeige
ich euch wie wir weitermachen ist
nämlich ein sehr sehr schnelles Rezept
[Musik]
[Applaus]
habe ich erwähnt dass es ein vier
Zutaten Rezept ist also ich brauche echt
nur Blätterteig jetzt kommt Zutat 2 und
3 Wasser und traubensirup und später nun
noch ein bisschen Sesam beim Wasser ist
es so dass wir das brauchen um den
traubensirup ein bisschen zu verdünnen
und traubensirup ist das aller aller
mein Gott so und jetzt wird unser
traubensirup verdünnt traubensirup ist
das aller aller Wichtigste beim Semit
und ich habe hier meinen eigenen
traumsirup warum habe ich traubensirup
bei mir im Shop es ist so random
irgendwie aber als ich mein Zimt Rezept
gemacht habe habe ich gemerkt es kommt
ganz viele Fragen und viele wussten gar
nicht wo sie den jetzt genau herbekommen
einige wohnen ja vielleicht auch
dörflich und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ich suche eine kleine Manufaktur
die das in Bio-Qualität herstellen kann
für mich und so ist mein biotraubensirup
entstanden so es kommt jetzt hier einmal
mit zum Wasser und dann werden wir
einfach die Kringel da ganz kurz
eintunken ganz kurz und dann richtig
schön in sesamwälzen da ist es auch egal
ob jetzt schon vorgerüsteten Sesam nehmt
oder ungerösteten weil es wird ja
sowieso im Backofen noch mal geröstet
[Musik]
so fertig sind meine fakesemit 210 Grad
Ober- und Unterhitze hatte ich
eingestellt schön vorheizen und dann
brauchen sie 22 Minuten bis sie so
aussehen also richtig schön goldbraun
ich lasse jetzt noch mal ein bisschen
abkühlen weil sie schon sehr heiß sind
und dann würde ich sagen machen wir den
Test die testi mit dem Hansa
[Musik]
hallo so ich habe sie mitgemacht
hamzaiten
ist aber auch nicht liegen
mit ohne Pac-Man
Entschuldigung
eine blättrige Angelegenheit
[Musik]
ja also genau richtig dieses süße ist ja
so typisch für sie mitnehmen
umrühren jetzt kommt der
momentchen und dann im Backofen 22
Minuten 32 Minuten
zum Frühstück einlade würde ich das Safe
machen das ist einfach beeindruckend
ja mit der herzhaften und süßen
das heftig finde ich gut macht gerne
nach und ansonsten sehen wir uns bei
meinem nächsten Video ihr Lieben tschüss
ciao
[Musik]